bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a full
house here with me today
i've got my brother i've got ken gold
and i've got ross hoffman
all of us are here we're gonna do four
people so thanks so much for tuning in
uh let's start maybe with joe why don't
you explain why you're here and then
we'll get to uh our guest
yeah i mean i've been on uh i've been on
the podcast one or two times now i think
so maybe some of you guys know
uh kind of what i do and what i'm up to
but i talk sports business so part of
that obviously covers the
sports memorabilia and kind of
collectibles industry
so i'm excited to kind of talk to not
only ken but ross and and hear more
about kind of uh
what what the future plans are for
golden and all that kind of stuff
did you just come on the podcast and
flex right off the bat with i've already
been on the podcast before
yeah i wanted to let everyone know that
it's i'm not a first timer here
all right well let's get to our first
timers uh ken maybe we'll go with you
and then ross
uh just tell a little bit about your
background what you're doing today
sure so i am founder and chairman of
golden auctions which i started in 2012.
i'm really a lifelong collector and
dealer i started collecting as
an eight-year-old i started buying and
selling as a 12 year old
you know i'm one of these kids who grew
up in the
late 1970s early 80s before the internet
before there were price guides
so i pretty much bought and sold cards
uh bought my first car
paid my way through college and uh
really have been doing this uh my entire
life
in the late 1980s i started the company
with my father called
scoreboard and we um you know we
ended up manufacturing our own trading
cards as well as
starting putting athletes on tv
in 1998 i started golden sports and for
20 years put athletes
on television sold product through the
networks and
as the tv shopping business slowed i
came up with the idea to open up
my best and likely my uh last business
which
is uh golden options which is really the
first business that
has been uh incredibly scalable
and that everything i envision that we
can accomplish or actually
able to do as opposed to having some
restriction where
people can't handle the work we throw at
them so golden auctions is the world's
largest uh sports auction house
and uh every record you heard about
being broken in 2020 whether it was a
mike trout card for 4 million
lebron james card for 1.8 million um
a giannis card for 1.9 million all those
record sales that seem to boggle the
mind and happen every week uh came from
us
awesome ross yeah so i i've been a
consumer operator
most of my career last 16 years uh
started out on youtube was an early
employee there
convincing people believe it or not to
put content on youtube telling them one
day they make money
sending boxes to people's houses to get
their vhs tapes that we could then
upload to the platform um saw twitter
happening and thought
it was a really interesting platform
initially was like a search engine for
me in san francisco mostly bayer usage
joined theirs and early employees stayed
seven years helped scale the business
ran a bunch of different teams
uh then wanted to go outside of ad based
consumer business want to learn about
subscriptions so
i was recruited to join headspace as
chief business officer
um and i uh i stayed there two years
helped build up the business diversify
the revenue
and then actually went on the venture
side uh both
at different ends of the spectrum one
was on the siege uh seat side with
uh howard lindsey and the team in social
leverage and the other was with the tcg
team
on the growth equity side um i spent
about a year and a half
uh working with tcg identifying
interesting companies and
you know we met ken we've been going
really deep in the space and we're
excited to partner
i uh i'd say through a lot of my career
has been picking the right market and
the right
asset in the right market i don't think
i deserve uh most of the success i've
had in terms of the credit i think i've
been able to pick the right market and
pick the right asset
we certainly think we did that with gold
absolutely and so you've stepped in as a
ceo
that's right yeah ken and i met for the
first time in uh
queue two q3 last year spent a lot of
time together
in person on zoom facetime various text
apps
i'm working to get them on slack we'll
see if we can make that happen um
and uh yeah i was excited about the
opportunity when ken
had offered it i jumped at the chance
absolutely
joe kick it off for us what questions
you got for these guys
i don't know i mean i think it'd be
helpful a lot of people i don't think
understand kind of the scale of where
golden is now right like i know the
business has grown a lot over the past
couple years and specifically
uh in 2020. so again maybe it's helpful
if you just give us kind of an overview
of where golden's at now
um as opposed to kind of where you guys
started in 2012 i think it was right
so in 2012 um i'll start with the story
when i came up with the business
you know we did 800 000 in our first
year 2012.
and i said to my wife if i can grow this
business to 10 million dollars a year
you know i'll have a nice business for
myself and i can retire when i want to
so we did 800 000 in 2012 we grew that
steadily
up to 27 million in 2019
did about 103 million in 2020
and um closure is ross we will do about
80 million dollars
uh for the year through the end of this
weekend
and i said that on a broadcast because
i just tell like it is we we were
running at
an amazing pace uh you know ross calls
me pac-man
because he says you know i just gobble
up the gmv
and my joke with him is i make the money
and he spends it
because i'm used to running a tight ship
you know i ended i ended last year with
21 employees
i think i've got 35 now
and i might have a hundred by the end of
july
so we're really scaling up the business
to uh
as opposed to being something where the
millionaires ultra wealthy and
billionaires can shop
and get the best authenticated
memorabilia trading cards and
collectibles and it's not just sports
i mean people don't even know do you
know the record for the highest priced
album music album ever
what that is no it's 900
000 it's for john lennon album and we
sold it in december
so um it's really any type of uh
collectibles
so uh realistically we did an auction in
january that did 33 million
we've got one ending on march 6th and
7th
that will break that i won't say by how
much but i will say it will break it
and we've scaled up from four auctions a
year in 2018
to seven in 2020 to a
minimum of 24 this year and i say
minimum
because as soon as i get the new
platform that i was promised
three months ago uh we will be able to
run
multiple um multiple departments so i
can run a trading card auction on one
side
an autograph auction on another a comic
book auction on another
and all of it seamlessly going at the
same time
so ross talk a little bit maybe about
the platform right it's not very obvious
that ken built this amazing business
uh really has been the face of kind of
collectible auctions for a while now and
i think people know golden auctions uh
they trust it
uh and there's this amazing marketplace
you come from
kind of much more of a an investing and
a technology background
what do you see as the low-hanging fruit
and kind of what are you guys going to
do to the business to kind of augment
and push this business forward
sure before i do i want to correct ken
i'm not spending the money i'm investing
the money i throw
a there's a fine line man um yeah look
we uh
we want to build a very stable platform
that
is for those that have been in the hobby
for a long time who
trust golden whether they're selling and
they can trust golden but they're going
to get
the best price possible whether they
trust gold and the
the buyers are going to be accredited
and they're not going to default on that
purchase
or on the buy side that you're going to
get what you pay for and i think the
auction technology that needs to sit in
the middle of buyers and sellers needs
to function
very smoothly needs to be a clean ui um
and really needs to be
at the end of the day i think we need to
be a data company where we're going to
be aggregating a lot of data and being
able to leverage that in ways that
benefit the consumer
so only one person wins each option
right there's
there's one winner but there's a lot of
people that don't win how are we able to
show them other things that they might
want to
that they might want to own uh how do we
make it easier for
uh sellers to find more buyers and how
do we make it easier for buyers to find
the things that they love
at the highest level that's what we want
to focus on over time it'll evolve
the the back end of that product that i
just described is actually fairly
technically complex
so it's going to take some time to do
but we have a first version that we're
excited about i actually saw a demo of
it earlier today
that's getting there and uh we're going
to iterate very quickly we uh
we don't want we don't believe in i
think there's two different
methodologies of shipping product you
could wait till it's perfect and ship it
or you could
kind of ship and mine as you go we're
definitely going to be the latter
and i think given ken being the face of
the hobby
um we get great feedback from the
community so we want to you know many of
our features will likely be built
from our community just as like the
hashtag and the ad sign we're built
by the twitter community we intend on
evolving as we go
but you can imagine it's a very social
experience a very graphically
easy and intuitive experience that's
very photo and video forward
uh and it's very community based those
are kind of three themes that we're
focusing on
as we develop the product absolutely and
so
uh when you guys think about kind of how
big this market is i know can you talk a
lot about the growth of uh
of gold and maybe ross explained like
you guys not only did a financial
transaction here but you stepped in
kind of on the operational side like how
big is this thing and
uh how big do you think it can get i
think that's the big question everyone
has right is
are we just in the early innings and
this thing's gonna you know 50x over the
next couple of years or is this
something where
no maybe we've seen how big the market's
gonna get it's what we have now and now
it's just who can get the most market
share
yeah so i think um i think the market's
going to continue to grow up what people
don't realize is the market's been
growing since around
2015 2016. so while this may be things
that people
suddenly uh are aware of they've been
happening for a long time and ken and i
talk about this a lot as well as
uh with the team at tcg that there's a
few
what we view as macro level tailwinds
that are happening and that's what i
talk about when you want to find a
find a market that is growing
organically and it's growing at a high
clip and then find the best asset in
that market
we think this market's growing
organically there's quant and there's
qual
i'd say the qual is a combination of
passion
and pop culture so passion you know
insert athlete is my favorite athlete
and i want to follow them and i want to
feel connected to them
pop culture is this is becoming a modern
day flex
where athletes or celebrities are
posting about their cards on instagram
or two of our
investors that we're fortunate to have
tim lin and sean watson posting
having lunch with the rock and they have
a psa 10 uh dwayne the rock johnson
university of miami miami
uh bumble bee tuna carton um so i think
that's partially driving it the second
two things i'd say more on the on the
quant side are one just an inflationary
hedge so i don't want to invest like the
previous generation
i don't want to set it and forget it and
retire when i'm 70. i'm looking for
more of an edge i want to uh you know
inflationary heights the u.s is pretty
more money since cova than they ever
have
so people know that their money sitting
in cash is not the best use of their
money they're actually losing money so i
think that's one lens the other i would
say
is uh gambling and fantasy sports which
is a huge huge business that's only
going to get bigger you know gambling
the us is not yet legal in texas and
california that's a
massive amount of people that at some
point that's most likely going to happen
um if you want to be a fantasy gm and
you want to go along a player
you know maybe you're in a keeper league
and you could keep that player over time
and most people aren't
you could buy you could buy their cards
you could go along a player and have a
thesis that
lamella ball is going to be an all-time
best player in the nba
and you're really long on him and you
think he's undervalued uh so there's a
lot of
i think there's a lot of fantasy and
gambling elements as well and if you add
the three of them up we think that's
going to
continue to drive the market forward
every market has ups and downs and i'm
sure that when there's some sort of
slow slowdown in the market there's
going to be tons of headlines that you
know
this was a bubble and it's not just like
you've seen with technology companies
i joke that like we used to say when's
the first trillion dollar company going
to be here
and you know then apple went to 2
trillion a couple months later and now
there's like 5 trillion
companies so i think uh people don't
know people don't adequately appreciate
the scale of the internet
and when you can take that and you can
layer on good technology good operations
and good content
which i don't want to talk about the
content side of things later we think we
can further accelerate that market and
that's what our plan is
and then and to add on to that talk
about the size of the market and we
estimated
that it was a 10 billion dollar market
in that 10 billion dollar market the
following
still goes on you know a friend of mine
distributes to every walmart in north
america
to uh for all the trading card product
he has people who follow his trucks
around
and as soon as they go there they you
know they follow the truck see where
they're making a delivery and then they
run in and clean out the shelves it's a
10 billion dollar market with
stuff disappearing the second it hits
the
the shelves it's a 10 billion dollar
marketplace with me receiving
i receive and i'm still at the phase
where i do it myself
you know you know you may not you you
may maybe pass that but i'm still at the
phase
where i actually read and reply to every
single
direct message i get at ken golden on
instagram you know i wake up in the
morning i get to
300 you know some people just being
cheerleaders we love what you're doing
other people's ask me questions other
people say
they want to consign stuff other people
are asking my opinion but i respond and
i see
all these people that are emailing me
overnight from the philippines from
macau
from hong kong from australia their
biggest thing is they cannot get product
so they they there is no no
good way that exists right now to
distribute your product overseas
when i started the business in 2012 less
than one percent of my business
was international in 2014 i had one
asian customer that's a company that you
know was about two percent of my
business because they bought a lot now
if i sell a basketball item about 30 to
40 percent of my bids are coming
internationally
if i sell a soccer item 60 and you know
how much soccer i sold in even 2017
zero i looked at my catalog i don't
think i had a single single soccer card
now soccer is fourth and if you take out
brady and mahomes from football
soccer is actually third behind
basketball and baseball
so i look right now for a 10 and all and
there are the supply the demand is 100
times supply
and you can't even feed any place except
north america
i think there i think that we are in the
early innings and there's a long way to
go
before all those marketplaces are
satisfied
and more people are getting into it
every single day that's what i'm seeing
on my database
with users is just it's all over the
world every day these people register
for golden and i gotta tell you
something
registering for golden's a pain in the
butt there's a lot of questions you
gotta fill out
you have to put in a credit card
information we have to verify you
so people are taking the time to do it
they are really serious about spending
money
yeah what else you got yeah i mean
ken that leads me to a good point right
like i think everyone uh kind of from
the outside looking in has noticed that
there's been a shift
and not only sentiment around the
industry but kind of like they see the
record sales whether it's the 4 million
for the trout or the lebron or whatever
it might be
i'm curious if there's like a time in
the past call it like 12 or 18 months
even
that you're like wow things are really
escalating right like whether it's the
the the walmart trucks people are
following whether it's uh you know more
messages you wake up in the morning
uh but like when did you realize that
things are really changing
well for me it started in 2016. we had
an auction called the great american
card auction and i came up with the idea
because i got a consignment
of the t206 wagner the famous jumbo
wagner of the five
so i said i have to build you know with
my background dealing with you know
dealing with companies like ubc you
can't have one item you need
you know your program you know you i got
to build an hour so to me
i look at a catalog i don't look and
that's the other thing we do differently
i don't look at as an auction as an
auction i look at every
every time we do an auction as an event
so okay how do i make this a big event
how do i build an event around this card
that hopefully
sells for a record at the time which was
2.8 million so that was my goal to sell
this card
for more than 2.8 million and to have an
event so i started um
i started um accumulating items and
advertising for this auction someone
came to me
with a 2003 lebron james card and i'm
sitting here with a 52 mickey mantle
it's going to sell for half a million
dollars
a hank aaron rookie in a 9 that's going
to sell for four hundred thousand
oh honest wagner i hope it's gonna sell
for three million dollars
a uh ty cobb that's gonna sell for 400
i'm saying why are you giving me this
card produced in 2003 you know
i was still the time that you know that
was garbage it's modern cards he goes
ken you gotta trust me i know you may
not understand this yet
but i think this card might actually
sell for a hundred thousand dollars i
said okay
you're a good consigner you're a good
customer i will put this lebron james
card in there
the lebron james card i put in there was
called the alt
2003 ultimate logo man it sold for three
hundred
and twelve thousand dollars we did set
the record that day
for the most valuable card of all time
3.1 million dollars for the wagner but
all the reporters want to talk about
is how this car that was printed only 13
years ago of lebron james
sold for over 300 000. so that's when i
said okay
forget everything else i'm doing the
rest of the staff you guys do everything
else i am diving into the modern cards
i've got to learn everything about this
business
and that's when i noticed a really big
change the other big change happened
in 2000 at the end of 2019 i got in this
collection from overseas called the
exquisite collection
and none of these cards are very rare
cards they're limited every single card
is numbered they're like one of one
one of 15 one of 99. it just
did enormous numbers sold for three four
five times whatever those cards were
selling for
and i said okay this is it and then
finally
people say well did covet kickstart this
people forget what happened in january
of 2019.
in january of 2019 we sold a basketball
card
featuring lebron james and michael
jordan called the logoman
for 900 000 it was an exquisite logo
so and that's what really set the whole
market that's when
that's when everything started going
crazy and yes covet hit and yes the land
stands
last dance hit but in january of 2020
was when people really were clubbed over
ahead
to put that in perspective the prior
record for a basketball card
was 451 000 and that was alexander's
rookie
and that ultimate logo man we sold in
2003
for 312 000 has a value today probably
of 10 million dollars
that's crazy ross how do you take uh
somebody like ken who is uh
such a great founder build a great
business uh has this massive
online platform and basically just build
the tools around him to kind of double
and triple down on the content business
and
obviously in 2012 content was very
different than it is today
um i know it's a huge focus for you guys
and i'm assuming ken's not going to uh
kind of build the company on the
strategy of like let's go on qvc every
day so how do you just think about
um you know kind of where you guys go
from here on the content side
yeah one of the first questions i assign
which i ask i ask anyone that i'm going
to work with is
what do you love doing think you're best
in class best in the world at and
what do you hate doing and think you're
really bad at and it's it's an
interesting question to hear how
objective people can be about themselves
ken was ken was very direct he was just
like look
i have the relationships i've built up
the trust and i'm the face of the hobby
i want to continue to drive that forward
i want to work with our consigners i
want to work with our buyers
i want to be out there and be a platform
for the hobby to lift everyone up
uh from the day-to-day operations you
know he built up a great business and
they were
they were good but he said look i think
i'm higher leverage to work on that it
was a great compliment for me
um i don't do a ton of media stuff um i
don't have deep knowledge in the in the
hobby
i'm a big sports man i collected as a
kid i collected
throughout my adult life but not nearly
the degree of ken um and i joke with him
he's a weighted average
i'm gonna say this on on the recording
now of uh i think he's 50
warren buffett of cards and 50 don king
of cards like
he knows every stat about every card and
is also an amazing amazing promoter for
the hobby
not just for golden but for the hub like
he he bleeds the hobby he's been in the
hobby longer than a lot of people in the
hobby
are alive so it was a conversation
around that and then okay like let's
let's actually take that and look at
that framework across the organization
and see
where pieces sit and let's just try to
play everyone's strengths i think you go
into a new
opportunity assuming that everyone's
great and giving them the opportunity to
disprove that or prove that but leading
with that assumption that
everyone is great in the processor and
then you listen you decide and then you
communicate right now i'm still in the
listening phase so
talking with the teams understanding how
they work really learning the process
you know working i asked ken a lot of
questions every day he's very patient
i'm trying to learn as much as i can as
fast as i can but um
i think really just playing people's
strengths understanding what they enjoy
spending time
doing what they don't then once you
understand that and you can really take
the vision i think the founding story
and you hear this a lot that the
founders and companies
um you know they they have their vision
they've obsessed over for a long time
and i think for ken it very much
predates the fountain of golden
like him as a 11 or 12 year old starting
in the hobby
uh buying his first amount of cards and
selling them for profit like he
he's been thinking about this for a long
time so really trying to squeeze that
out of him something that he
doesn't have to think about that's just
second nature but really trying to
understand that as to
what does he value why does he think the
business is the way it is where does he
think the industry is going
and try to ensure that you're using that
as the guardrails to to build a good
company around when it comes to
developing software and uh you know
supply chain
and operations and content like we could
rush and do all that right away what we
want to do is really be thoughtful and
build that around this vision and um
you know so far it's been a really good
partnership
for sure and in terms of uh the content
itself
like is it just more ken all the time
or do you have to eventually kind of
supplement ken with
all kinds of other um you know uh names
and brands
and different distribution points yeah
it's it's the latter i think like look
ken's always going to be at the court
uh he's always going to be the global
expert in the space when people call in
they want to talk to kent and ken's
going to be doing things like this and
on television and on instagram
and other social media platforms uh i do
think we do think you need to build
a platform around ken whether that's
through
full-time in-house talent whether that's
through partnerships with
uh you know very affable good-looking
brothers that happen to have their own
podcasts
it really depends but we uh we want to
build a large content set to play to
different audiences i view their
as two macro level audiences one is
those that are in the hobby already
and you need to come to them with an
authentic standpoint stop smiling come
on you're gonna make me
i'm laughing because i can literally
smell how bad my brother's breath is
through the computer
yeah you're just pissed he called me
good looking
yeah so the one audience is those that
are in the hobby um and the other is
those that want to come into the hobby
and i think you do
you talk to the former from an authentic
expertise standpoint and i think you
talk to the latter
from an expertise but also from an
education and an entertainment
standpoint
to have them understand and feel safe
there's a lot of people that invest out
there
there's a lot of people that want to
make profit out there or connect with
their passions out there
there's a lot of die-hard sports fans
who invest but if you brought them into
the hobby right now they wouldn't know
what to do
and that's a big problem but it's a
really big opportunity if we can build
the right technology
and the right tools and pricing guides
and on-ramps for them to come in by
by really bringing the right data and
putting in front of them we think that's
a big opportunity
and one thing i want to mention why we
talk about technology so people
understand
what golden has accomplished we are
literally using software
from 2002. so everything we've
accomplished
is no joke is from a 2002
platform that has been band-aided over
the years so you can see how i am like
waiting very impatiently to have this
remarkable new product that's uh
designed in uh in 2021
joe what else other questions you got no
i think um
on my side like i think ross brings up a
good point and i'm kind of curious how
golden as a platform is going to change
right because i think
with everything all the numbers and the
headlines and everything i personally
get
yeah i'd say it would be three buckets
one is from a product standpoint
there'll be
features that we build out to make it
very easy to either
upload your current collection or look
at you know
list out things that you want and
basically build a want list that you can
track in one place i'd love to be
people's hub for their the overall hobby
including cards that they have not
bought on golden but they want to have
stored in one place
second would be from a content
perspective
so actually just creating educational
content whether that's
newsletters podcasts videos uh
glossaries
indices just things that can make them
feel more informed about
what's the difference between an rpa and
a prism
and what's the difference between a base
prism and an orange prism or a pink
prism
i'd say third would be uh on top of the
first two
is data so if we can aggregate data
around pricing
people always say like well how much
should i pay
i don't i don't know and who should why
are there 50 different rookie cards or a
thousand different
types of cards for this one person so if
you can combine those three things with
a better easier ui
you can also have better content that
tells the story and then better pricing
data where they feel safe making that
decision
just like you have analyst reports in
the public markets you should have
technology product and content that
tells that story in golden with the
right data that's very easy to consume
so you can come in from day one
make informed decisions whether you're a
collector an investor or both and feel
safe about what you're doing
ken we got to hear the wildest story you
got man i feel like you got some
crazy crazy life experiences doing all
this what's the craziest thing that
you've experienced and no one else has
ever heard
that story the one the story you just
thought of is the one that we want to
hear
well i've had some i've had some really
really really
unusual experiences really great
experiences i mean i've met
you know i've met a number of
ballplayers um you know i can go back
from you know when i was a little kid
and somebody came into me with about
1500 tobacco cards
including like 16 thai cobbs and i paid
him a dollar a card
um which i don't know how many millions
of dollars that would be worth
um a lot of you know you know from from
the
you know from the auction stories a real
good one is somebody came to me
literally last week they bought a
um a pack when they were you know when
they were younger
and it was a 2000 playoff contenders
football pack and they went to a card
shop paid eight dollars bought a pack
pulled a tom brady card and the guy said
tomorrow that's probably worth a few
hundred dollars you should protect that
so they put it into a sleeve and they
put it in a holder
and it stayed there for 21 years they
somehow saw me on tv or some somewhere
and they contacted me
they drove down from massachusetts last
week to my office
pulled the card out it's card number 95
out of 100
playoff contenders tom brady rookie card
uh we got it graded came back in 8.5
with a 10 autograph
which means that their eight dollar
purchase in 2000
is gonna sell for close to two million
dollars so um
that is um that's a good one
um what what's the most unusual thing
these are all
stories of people making money what's
the like the craziest most unusual thing
craziest well i i think possibly selling
uh when we sold brady's uh underwear
we sold uh joe frazier's uh jockstrap
from the flight of the century
number one um we it it's it's it's
unbelievable stuff that uh that
that people keep um i actually heard a
story
from the opposite end of a deal that i
negotiated in my 20s with shaquille
o'neal
you know i remember pounding up against
his age and trying to get him exclusive
and i've got a picture in my office of
me
and shaq at his first game and i got a
picture i posted on instagram
that i happen to find luckily because my
ex-wife threw away a lot of my pictures
um not nothing with a bad relationship
but she was making a collage
and he was cutting out cutting out these
collages and this one was spared and it
was me
with shaquille o'neal at madison square
garden
him giving me a hug right after he was
drafted number one wearing the orlando
cap
and me holding up his card that i
produced for him
with um produced him with uh
you know with his likeness that was
exclusive but what i heard
was years later him giving an interview
with panini and it's a panini interview
and he's talking about his first ever
deal his first ever million dollars
and he goes uh this guy ken golden sent
my agent a deal and he was going to pay
me a million dollars up front
and uh my agent was telling me you know
leonard was saying we want to ask for
more and
i said no give the man the deal
sign the contract this is a million
dollars for a trading card you call that
young man right now on the phone and you
tell him
that that he's got a deal and um it was
it was it was great to hear from that
perspective
that i actually could have been jacked
for another 500 grand
but uh shaq said no it's uh
it's it's it's uh it's good we're good
but um you know
the athlete stories are always um you
know always for me the
uh you know the best i mean i think back
in you know i sat with you know hank
aaron in the 1980s and you know
you know for hours and hours and hours
and he's gone now
but i think you know i was with this guy
literally
only 10 years after he retired so it's
kind of like
you know i was so young in this industry
that so much happened around me that
you know now i appreciate it i wish i
did i wish i took a lot more pictures of
it and i wish i
saved a lot more um a lot more stuff but
um
there is there's uh
crazy i mean i'd have to uh i'd have to
think and i'd have to think if i'm even
allowed to tell some of the uh
some of the i know i know you're
thinking of some crazy stories you're
not saying
oh god yeah yep yeah yeah yeah so
um so we had a contract with gretzky
and um he had his jersey staller
from the spectrum and we ordered
jerseys that were specific to um
specific to the player to his size and
specifications
so we got a call from his agent michael
barnett and said how far away you got to
the spectrum we said well
we're in cherry hill new jersey we're
like 15 minutes because you need to
bring can you bring one of wayne's
jerseys and um
you know we luckily he didn't sign it
first because we had him ready from the
side he didn't sign it
so he wore one of the jerseys and then
he gave it back to us after the game
so you know i got to keep a um you know
i got to keep a gretzky uh
game warren um i got to keep a gretzky
game more in jersey
but you know some of the stuff is um you
made me the gretzky now i was thinking
about um
thinking about another ridiculous one
with um
you here to prep me for that one i i'll
i'll i'll have it for next time
but the problem joe you got any more
questions
you are you gonna write a thread about
uh golden auctions now can we get a time
for a thread
awesome ross i want to finish with you
uh as you kind of think about this you
know just zoom out and kind of look
forward 5-10 years
what's kind of the vision for where you
guys end up
you know kind of in the medium term so
not necessarily 25 years from now not
next year but just somewhere in that
medium term what's kind of the goal
yeah i think we want to continue to
cement ourselves is the easiest place to
buy and sell online
where if you've got an item that you're
that you're ready to list you know that
you're going to get the best price
you're going to get it in the easiest
way possible
and if you're going to buy you know
you're going to get what you're actually
paying for
i think i could see in a world in five
years where we're outside of what we're
known for which is sports and we've
diversified more
into other verticals and it's a mobile
first experience that's very consumer
and social driven
and a very large community layer on top
of that
um so i think we can accomplish that
before five years from now but that's
that's where we'd like to be
makes uh makes sense ken where can we uh
find you on the internet
if somebody listens to this that doesn't
know where you are
um at ken golden at ken golden on
twitter at
ken golden on uh instagram and of course
at golden auctions uh everywhere and i
wait wait i've got a tick tock
oh this my i made a tick tock i recorded
something about the honest wagner
and all of a sudden my daughter contacts
me who's 21 years old and like
tries to live on tick tock and she goes
how the hell do you have 500 000 views
and you've been on tick tock for four
days
i've posted 60 videos and i haven't
broken a thousand yet
so that that shows you how trading card
crazy the world is i mean i'm
you know i'm not i'm not doing a dance
i'm not you know the social media guy
said we're making you tick-tock i said
i'm not dancing
um he goes no you're gonna talk about
cards and i said okay how's that gonna
be interesting
so i did three four things i talked
about cards and
all of a sudden i've got maybe maybe by
now six hundred thousand views
so but yeah just at ken golden
everywhere and hopefully you find me
i love it ross where can we find you uh
hoff on twitter
all right joe i know you came on here
you flex already you've been on the
podcast go ahead and pitch your uh your
newsletter
all right i'm gonna send you a uh a
little uh invoice for some bitcoin after
you get a pitch in the free advertising
all right guys listen thank you guys so
much for uh for doing this i think that
uh the business obviously speaks for
itself
and uh the world is definitely sporting
card drunk right now which is
which is fun because i i kind of agree
with you guys that it's only going to
continue to grow
and uh wish you guys the best for big
fans and uh can't wait to see what you
guys do next
thanks thanks for having us